[Music]
i look outside from rock on the wind
i can grind yes or
no man does not eat grain but must
first grind
the mail so eat bread
i am maarten doorman and i am gona
discreet backstories is inspired by
knowledge is
dolls
but tennis man on the last few
opinion miller's and holland type the
foundation islam and the wind-up
ovation is and along which is murderous and cheese
and mails and the netherlands
took it home realizes the fryske marren
click now we are about thirteen
hundred complete windmills in  the netherlands
and that is 50 millers who
grind the flour for consumption
modint is called great pride and is professor
it is cheese family is evident that is
a pint of milk you must is one of the most
famous info spring
this fashion is also exactly like that
any like the one built in 1732
it is called one of the largest
flour mill say you about 32
meters in its totality the mill
is powered by the wind and then
through wooden gear  len company that very
large millstone on such a millstone that
kilos with a good profit we can
grind a thousand kilos a day that is 5000
kilos and the week
and the special thing is that mail that you grind
with stones with a
windmill so its  natural string and keep its
back smell my flour is
used for
bread maker it is all about the base
largest product is with us we
say we made a wholemeal flour tonight
in addition is very high level angle
and cake mixes bread mix and there is a
linseed sesame seed
well so  there are various products
every day martin family to live is
freshlyground flute 2 doko bakeries
i like the flour of the wind
that it uses because your
professional skills are somewhat stimulated the
flour the an email is always
something else you stay in the
different types of bread also the
egteren taste
the demon is a culture representative
at the mailing practical application of
this knowledge and hopes t  hat tradition
millingen last of many generations comb
your website of the craft debate
rating wind mails per tracks and
unesco hope for the future is actually
keep people enthusiastic about
the mill
there are just beautiful mode the beautiful
face and just working with the
mill itself they just have the mane and
keeping the mill in operation
that gives a bit of satisfaction
you just feel at ease when the mill is
grinding
[Music]